uh do we have any updated numbers is is
this the worst of it or is there more to
come here um there this is not the
extent of the hack this is the extent of
of what by law JP Morgan had to report
disclosure laws are pretty weak in the
US they tend to go state byst state the
things that they do have to report is uh
theft of customer data S names uh email
addresses birth dates anything like that
what they don't have to report is what
else these hackers might have got in
terms of corporate data emails Trading
strategies algorithms source code none
of that actually has to be reported so
we don't know if this is the extent of
the attack we do know that the hackers
took a huge amount of information if you
look at those numbers that's just about
every single account the that what that
this bank has in the US plus some
overseas it's a huge huge number uh is
this isolated
Mike you know that's that there are uh
in terms of of these particular hackers
there are reports that in
fact that JP Morgan is not the only bank
that is that has been hit um if other
banks have been hit they could have been
in Europe or they could have just not
disclosed yet um uh it's unusual for
hackers like this just to take one
target I imagine that they are working
in other places so we just may have to
wait and see